hello everyone and welcome to the third
day of the world rapid Championship it
is Magnus Carlsen versus Vincent kymer
this is round 10 and the Magnus is
currently in Seoul lead if you've seen
my previous video these were the
standings at the end the Magnus leading
with seven and a half points followed by
uh fedosotrov and Vincent kaimer who is
his opponent for this game and uh this
is uh I mean it's such a such a great
game such a such a high level game that
I'm I I feel absolutely privileged to be
able to show this to you uh you will
enjoy this on every possible level uh so
let's dive straight into it Magnus with
the white pieces opens with C4 and okay
uh if if you're looking at the Vincent's
rating it's only 25 90 and 90 when I say
only 25.90 I say as he is in class clay
2700 player he just doesn't play rapid
all that much uh so I'm sure you guys
know that he uh okay now currently he's
like
26.96 or something like that but he is
definitely a 2700 player so C4 by Magnus
Knight to FC 6 with D4 E6 and now Knight
to F3 we have Pawn to D5 the Queen's
gamber decline this on the board and the
Magnus goes for G3 going for the Catalan
opening showing that he is done with the
funky openings for the first two days he
played uh a lot of weird stuff okay in
the second day he played a bit more more
solid but now he throws out the Catalan
which means that now he is going to
really throw uh everything he has at
Vincent uh Vincent goes for D captures
on C4 we have Bishop to G2 and now
already uh uh a bit of a surprise from
Vincent uh he plays C6 usually here you
will see A6 you will see C5 you will see
Knight the C6 you will see Bishop to B
for check C6 is only the sixth most
popular continuation but as this is
something that was prepared for the
wheelchairs Championship I I'm pretty
sure it doesn't come as a surprise to
Magnus he throws the Knight to the E5
which is a great Square especially now
you don't have the C6 Square for your
knight and Bishop to B4 with check
uh we have Bishop to D2 and now Bishop
back to E7 Magnus also weighs the tempo
now Bishop to G5 H6 we have Bishop
characters and F6 Bishop captures and
now Knight the A3 still waiting with the
uh capturing of the of the C4 Pawn
because if you do it with this Pawn then
the D4 Pawn would be hanging and here uh
it seems like you could go for some like
Bishop captures an E5 let's say the
captors Queen captures on D1 Rook
captures on D1 and B5 trying to keep
your Pawn but this runs into the uh the
oldest trick in the book of Knight
captures on B5 and of course one of the
reasons why the Knight is developed the
A3 so instead Vincent goes for Queen to
A5 and it is now as of move 10 that we
have a completely new game uh the reason
why it's a completely new game is
because there is a game in the database
where C3 was played in C3 is kind of the
strongest move recommended by the engine
uh but um maybe Vincent just wanted to
play uh something more more solid
because as the C3 is pretty wild the B
captures on C3 then you capture with the
bishop here Queen A5 now attacks the
queen attacks the Knight and the pawn
here you have to defend and then Queen
captures an E5 uh pretty crazy stuff uh
the Queens are still on the board and
maybe this um uh well Vincent just
prefers a more uh comma approach as
Peter leko said uh he says that I feel
Vincent has a problem playing against
Magnus uh that they have a very similar
Styles simply that Magnus is still
clearly stronger uh he said that before
the game so here Queen to A5 check
completely new game and okay Magnus goes
for Queen to D2 and here we have a trade
Queen captures King captures Castles by
Vincent and now only now the pawn is
recaptured Knight captures on C4 uh Rook
to d8 attacks the D4 pawn and the Magnus
goes for King to E3 and here uh watch
this King for the rest of the game just
how strong the king is on E3 we have
Knights the D7 uh Vincent continues
development Rook H to D1 adding another
Defender to the D4 Pawn Knight to B6 now
and Magnus goes for F4 now you could uh
consider some other moves uh F4 is very
committal once you push upon you can't
unpush it but here a Magnus feels it is
very Justified and the reason for that
is if you play something like Bishop
captures an E5 you will play Knight
captures on E5 and now look at this F6
and how does uh White play this yeah the
problem is Knight the C4 check will pick
up the B2 Pawn so you have to bring the
Knight back to defend the pawn and now
after Knight to C4 check you will play
King to F2 and now give up the D4 Pawn
uh in order to go Knight to C5 now black
has to trade Rooks for example Rook
captures Rook captures and Rook to d8
check is a pretty big threat like um if
you grab another Pawn Rook the d8 check
look at this King to F7 and now Knight
captures on B7 and the white uh
definitely achieves something for
example Bishop capture Rook D7 checking
to f8 and now Rook captures here and
it's uh you know Vincent is up a pawn
but Magnus has the monster bishop and uh
he has a rook on the seventh rank that's
I mean he that that's a pig right there
and he will have a lot of compensation
for that pawn so instead Bishop to E7 by
Vincent uh with ideas of maybe even
re-maneuvering the uh Bishop the C7 uh
Rook 8 to C1 Magnus continues
development and only now F6 we have
Knight the D3 and here uh is the sort of
moment of the game
uh where Vincent has to be very very
careful here he played King to F7 uh
also you should consider Knight captures
on C4 because this Knight Will haunt
Vincent for the rest of the game the way
to do this is captors captures and now
execute E5 and now let's say d captures
uh captures and captures you can't
capture with the Knight because the Rook
would hang so F cap percentile Bishop to
E6 you give up one Pawn but you have the
bishop pair Magnus has a double e Pawn
this is how you uh well gain a lot of
activity but Vincent wanted to avoid
this he played King to F7 first and now
Magnus plays Knight to A5 and here uh it
will be very very difficult if not
impossible to activate your pieces with
black this Knight is such a nuisance
here uh I mean uh an incredible piece so
Vincent goes Rook to B8 he wants to be
able to develop the bishop the B7 Pawn
has to be protected and Bishop to F3 you
will also see how strong this move is we
have Bishop up the D6 now Vincent re
wants to re-maneuver the bishop to C7
and now King to F2 Magnus finally moves
that King from E3 and now prepares E4
maybe he wants to slow play it maybe E3
but maybe also just e for E5 uh Vincent
says all right Knight to D5 and now Pawn
to A3 not allowing any freeing Knights
to be for moves uh Bishop to C7 attacks
the Knight and now while you might
expect something like Knight B3 or
Knight the C4 Magnus plays the mood that
is almost always the strongest moving
chess and that is Pawn to B4 uh saying
okay if you want a capture you can
double my pawns but you are never
developing your queen side uh and the
problem is unless you capture you don't
really have a a better a better move
because uh you can't you can never play
B6 the C6 Pawn will be incredibly weak
and other than that your options are
very limited maybe just the waste time
with some like Bishop to B6 or something
but it doesn't really achieve all that
much so maybe maybe best for black would
be just to play a waiting game but
Vincent accepts the challenge he plays
Bishop captures on A5 B captures an A5
and now Bishop to D7 now the C6 Pawn is
defended so he doesn't have to worry
about Rook captures on C6 and he is now
ready to execute B6 and okay Magnus
plays E4 attacks the Knight Knight
Knight the C7 and now while you would
again expect Knight to B4 to prevent B6
as a knight before puts additional
pressure to C6 Magnus just brings the
king back to E3 and he says B6 is is
still not an issue for me because if B6
now he can still play Knight to B4 and
put pressure on that C6 pawn and now
after cat person captures you have to
capture otherwise one of the Rooks will
hang and now Rook characters on C6 and
again Magnus gets a very very promising
position uh for example even if Knight
the B5 you can play Bishop to G4 also
one of the reasons why that Bishop to F3
maneuver was uh so strong so instead
after this um Bishop to this sorry after
this King they eat removed Vincent plays
the should be back to E8 again sort of a
winning move opens up the file for the
rook and only now Knight to B4 putting
more pressure on that C6 Pawn King to E7
and now Magnus strikes in the center
with Ponte E5 the situation on the clock
here is seven minutes for Magnus and two
minutes and some 45 seconds for Vincent
uh as it's uh not easy to find moves
here for black so Magnus gains a more
space by playing E5 but he gives up the
the control over the D5 Square so
Vincent immediately puts the Knight
there and now not Knight captures that
Knight is just a monster controlling the
entire Queen side Bishop captures on D5
we have C captures uh you also could
consider this but then F5 and I mean
this is just incredibly strong uh
controlling all of those squares you
would not have fun playing this so
instead C captures on D5 and now Magnus
wins the C file for his Rooks we have
Rook D7 and Rook D to C1 if um
the trade then Magnus gets the other
Rook into the game so F captures an E5
and now D captures an E5 uh while uh you
could also consider F characters and E5
this will pose more problems for black
one's G for F5 comes uh it will be very
hard to defend the downside is that it
gives Vincent a pass to D pawn and he
can just start pushing it he plays King
the d8 tries to force a rook trade here
but Magnus not interested he just brings
The Rook back and keeps all the tension
and you will still have problems playing
B6 because Knight the C6 check will just
destroy black so here Vincent starts
with the D4 check Magnus gave up some
Square so of course Vincent jumps at the
opportunity to claim them King to D2 and
Bishop to G6 now now the bishop Pawn
combo is doing a lot of good work here
but Magnus now goes for Pawn to A6
making any advances impossible because
of Knight the C6 check so Vincent plays
the only move he has Bishop to E4 and
now guards the B7 pawn and uh Vincent
was down below the 30 second Mark here
Magnus didn't want to invest too much
time but he did invest a minute for this
move and he plays Rook to B5 puts more
pressure Here and Now capturing is never
possible yeah I mean it never was
possible but now even The Rook here is
just straight out hanging so he forces
Vincent to go B6 and now uh he goes for
Knight to C6 with check showing that
this position will be winning for him
Bishop captures and C6 we have Rook
captures on C6 and now we have Rook the
C8 attacking that Rook King the E7 would
still sort of hold but uh we have rooked
the C8 Here and Now Magnus could go for
a lot of things here
uh for example Rook captures on C8 is an
option but he goes for Rook captures uh
on E6 the the reason why this is so
strong Rook captures King captures and
A4 is that there's no good way to defend
magnets will just attack this Pawn
eliminate the pawn and win the king and
pawn end game but okay this is just a
straight Pawn so Rook captures an E6 who
would not play this D3 and now just Rook
to D6 uh point is that Rook to C2 could
be a problem now so just Rook to D6 if
you play Rook to C2 the king can just
capture the pawn so Rook captures on D6
with E Capture some D6 and now King to
D7 going after the pawn but now Rook to
F5 Magnus just plays this with absolute
class showing that if you capture uh
just Rook deaths sorry definitely not
that Rook to F7 and now there's nothing
you can do this is hanging this is
hanging and if you block of course just
the king and pawn end game will be
completely winning for Magnus so here
King the E6 was played now D7 beautiful
stuff you here Rook to d8 and now the
position is again completely winning for
Magnus but it is up to you to help him
win it feel free to pause the video and
win the game for Magnus while I give you
a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting the only
winning idea it's the king and pawn end
game and for those of you who just want
to enjoy the show it is Rook the E5 with
check and now there is well there's
absolutely nothing you can do wherever
the King goes you're just gonna play
King D5 or Rook D5 and capture the the
pawn here and that's pretty much it so
and of course if you capture it's even
worse Rook the D5 checking C7 you trade
Rooks and again the king and pawn end
game is winning for white white is up
upon not much to be done here so King
the D6 was played and now Rook to E3
that's how you go after the Pawn King to
C6 Vincent knows that he cannot trade
Here and Now roof captures on D3 we have
King to B5 uh going for the spawn this
will give Vincent two points on the
queen side but just King to E3 once
again the king returns to the Glorious
E3 square and here you know you are four
moves away from resignation King
captures and A6 was played kingy for
Kingdom 7 and as he played King to B7 it
was also in this position animal 48 that
Vincent kaimer resigned in the game as
there is nothing more to be done here so
the game would continue with something
like King E5 King C7 you're gonna bring
the king to E6 now you can't capture
there's nothing for you to do you could
play a few more moons king or you will
attack the rook and now if King to C7
just Rook the C3 check will force the
king away from the rook and that's
pretty much it so brilliant brilliant uh
stuff by Magnus and definitely something
um to keep in mind that Peter leko said
that he feels that Vincent's style is
very very similar to magnus's only
Magnus just uh does it much much better
and it really the whole game can uh be
summarized with this one move uh where
Vincent decided to start bringing the
king into the game where in fact this
Knight captures on C4 move was an
absolute must he had to give up a pawn
here if you guys missed it or don't
remember here just Sakura fights upon
and after all the captures here Play
Bishop to E6 you have the Bishops pair
you have development uh you you will you
will be able to fight doesn't matter
that you're down upon activity is
compensation in itself but uh he he
decided to go King F7 and this Knight
the A5 move uh you can see how uh
principles in chess are are often
helpful in guiding us but sometimes they
are they are meant to be not just broken
just you know just absolutely destroyed
as here you put a knight on the on the
rim the Knight on the rim is a green but
as we say here the Knight was the Grim
Reaper uh so yeah that's the game hope
you guys enjoyed it uh I would like to
thank Jeff Graves David Rice Oxley Kevin
Clark Chris Malin and Rapid boss for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
video World rabbit Championship until it
finishes so thank you all I will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day